All right, good. Let's go next to why don't
we go to let's go to Harvey from from where
where is it from North Carolina. Harvey
from North Carolina. You're on the air.
Hey, David, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
OK, awesome.
So I basically am pretty worried
and terrified that twenty twenty two, twenty four
are going to be a bloodbath for the Democrats.
OK, just kind of wanted to lay out my case.
Why? And I get your thoughts on it. Sure.
So, you know, just the I think to start with, the
fact that we were unable to easily and clearly
defeat an incompetent moron like Trump in twenty
twenty, and the fact that it was as close as it
was that the Republicans picked up seats in itself
I thought was a pretty bad sign. Yep. I feel like
the I feel like the right has done a good job,
especially over the last year. And I feel like
they may be effective in doing this going
forward at tying the left, like the Democrats, to
a lot of cultural issues that are best
that that can be appealing to appealing to
sort of nonpartisan or apolitical people, sort of
like tying the Democrats to a canceled culture or
just political correctness and
identity politics and all that stuff.
And there I feel like their party has that,
like they're shifting into a more establishment
and a more anti-establishment party. At least
the esthetics are, even if they're not on the
policy. But I feel like politics is really
starting to matter less and less these days.
Yeah. And and also, I just feel like the fact
that on the left, I feel like we are really having
a civil war and the right is not like the right
wing base is pretty united behind Trump. It's only
like the D.C. politicians and media people that
are having the civil war. But even on the left,
our civil war isn't just establishment left versus
populist left. Like even in the populist left,
we have a lot like Jimmy Dorian, Glenn Greenwald
and everyone fighting against other progressives
on the left and stuff like that. And I just feel
like all of this is creating the perfect storm.
OK, so, yeah, that's that's that's a ton of
stuff. So I'll just mention a few things.
One is that I think the I'll go kind of
go backwards, the infighting on the left.
It's not clear to me that it's really having
electoral repercussions at this point in time,
because in the end, you've got a lot of people
who are very loud, but they don't vote regardless,
like they're not voting either way. So it kind of
doesn't matter whether they are in disagreement
with what's going on in the Democratic Party,
because either way, they're just they're tweeting,
but they're not actually voting. That's part of
it. Another part of it is that I, I think that
we you are right in being sort of concerned about
how difficult it was to defeat Trump in the end
and barely won the Senate, did Democrats and
lost some seats in the House. But I think that
there's a unique situation. Twenty, twenty four
I'm not even going to think about until after we
get twenty, twenty two for twenty, twenty two.
If it simply ends up being a referendum on did
Joe Biden get the economy back to sort of where it
was before the pandemic, the Joe Biden deal with
vaccination. Well, did Joe Biden get stimulus
done? Did Joe Biden get some other legislative
accomplishment? You may see a reversal of the
normal trend, which is one party wins the White
House and then two years later loses the House
and or Senate. You may actually see Democrats do
really well in November of twenty twenty two. I
think it's too soon to know. And and I think we
have to wait and see, but I think it's completely
plausible. Democrats do fine in twenty twenty two.
OK, well I just think Biden won't get enough done
to energize or to satisfy the progressive left and
keep them energized to come out in twenty, twenty
two. And then I guess sort of the last one that I
missed was I just feel like twenty, twenty two
alone is going to be a bloodbath because of the
gerrymandering that's going to come after
the census. As the Republicans control the
state legislatures, they're going to redraw the
districts to favor them. And and that's a real
issue. That's a real and in the and the electoral
map for twenty twenty four, even if there is
more votes that are shifting towards Texas and
Florida State from leaning more Republican. So
that those are just that's just why
I'm pretty concerned about that.
All right. Well, we're going to follow
it all, but I think your concerns are
reasonable and we'll have plenty of time
to discuss for sure. I appreciate the call.
Thank you, David. All right. Thanks to
everybody who called. I unfortunately need to
hang it up there, but we will take calls
again. And I hope to hear from you next time.